[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup je remercie d'ailleurs
tedx n'avoir invité à me poser des
questions sur le futur je dis que ce qui
me veulent au départ et bien moi le
futur
malgré ce qu'on peut entendre un peu
partout je devoir à dieu je le vois
merveilleux je le vois joyeux je suis
donc à l'évidence c'est ce qu'on appelle
un optimiste alors c'est facile de dire
qu'on est optimiste c'est plus rare les
gens qui disent ce moment je suis
pessimiste d'ailleurs les pessimistes
disent pas qu'ils sont pessimistes
je pas pessimiste je suis réaliste aux
quêtes bon je vais vous dire à partir
éléments étaient optimistes ou
pessimistes
tu envisages un futur qui n'est pas là
donc ce ne sont que des spéculations
néanmoins les mots sont hyper importants
c'est hyper important de formuler tout
simplement déjà en tant qu'artiste je
vous donne un exemple très simple je
pense pas que jules verne était un
visionnaire son lit et je voulais bien
c'est un visionnaire
non je pense que les scientifiques
manquent cruellement d'imagination
à la date les scientifiques voient que
jules verne a fait un truc qui vont
faire la même chose
c'est pour ça qu'un jour ça se revend
dira et james cameron il va fé
terminator c'était vraiment un
visionnaire aujourd'hui a vraiment des
robots qui tuent des gens adorent faut
vraiment faire attention à ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est génial je vois plein
de séries comme black mirror qui
dépeignent un futur un peu dark faut
faire attention à ce qu'on fait alors
l'optimisme ça passe déjà par peut-être
arrêter de critiquer les générations qui
arrivent il faut beaucoup ça moi ma
génération on a critiqué jusque
passionnant la salle concret
lectionnaire les pokémon alors ils sont
là on vous affichiez dessus clairement
et en même temps faut arrêter je veux
dire moi ma génération alors ça va être
très obscur ce que je vais vous dire
certains ne vous ne verront pas de quoi
je vais parler mais ma génération on a
collectionné c'est passionnant qui l'ont
fait on à collectionner les cartes de
cabine téléphonique
certains en ont entendu parler des
cabines téléphoniques ça n'existe plus
alors on avait les 50 et les 120 unités
et en laissant les collectionner vide
magrin alors aujourd'hui on critique les
réseaux sociaux critique saint pastou
vraiment faire très attention et je me
dis clairement si on a collectionné les
pokémon l'écart téléphoniques et
qu'aujourd'hui on a snapshot on court
droit vers le chaos
voilà vraiment faux faut le dire et
c'est là que je suis optimiste parce que
je ne pense pas que le chaos soit
quelque chose de négatif
non je pense que le chaos et peut-être
même nécessaire on a besoin de chaos
d'ailleurs l'histoire de la planète
terre ne s'est pas faite de façon
linéaire c'est fait ça a été jonché de
fractures de révolution et c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça que ça se passe
et pareil pour l'être humain on
exactement on fonctionne exactement
comme la terre on fonctionne déjà dans
notre physiquement alors que la terre
est faite essentiellement d'eau nous
aussi fer magnésium
nous aussi et pour aller mieux parfois
on a besoin d'un bon chaos dans notre
vie d'une bonne dépression après une
dépression parfois en sort grandie alors
on fait plusieurs petites micro
dépression surtout la joie qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes et des petites c'est
pas les mêmes des pressions que plus
tard là c'est plutôt des dépressions à
ne pas sortir avec moi je me suicide
ce genre de dépression et ça
chiale saint charles pour de rien c'est
et parfois ces dépressions elles sont
utiles elles sont utiles moi j'ai fait
des dépressions qui m'ont été surtout
une la plus grosse la plus grosse
dépression de ma vie eh ben ça m'a fait
comprendre beaucoup de choses mais on
peut être dépressif et rester optimiste
c'est possible je ne sais pas si parmi
vous y en a qui font des dépressions tu
penses que c'est la fin j'avais en moi
je chiale est tous les jours en touche
et doit monter sur scène pour faire rire
les gens
donc tu es vraiment dans un délire assez
complexe c'est complexe jeudi en
dépression je sais pas si parmi vous il
y en a qui vont se reconnaître mais j'ai
commencé à faire du sport jean j'étais
en dépression
allez on fait du sport on pousse on fait
du sport
ma vision du monde elle a complètement
changé elle a complètement changé je
regardais les body builder jeunes et de
l'huile a dû avoir des soucis de malades
clairement lui va morfler dans la vie
parce qu'être optimiste c'est déjà agir
et la terre c'est pareil je pense que la
terre la dépression c'est quoi c'est
pouvoir se regarder dans la glace et
j'ai fait sauter toutes les barrières
internes
alors j'ai décidé d'être honnête avec
moi à 100% j'ai fais péter tout ce que
j'avais comme barrière intérieurement et
je pense que le chaos de la terre va se
faire par l'explosion de toutes les
frontières
il faut péter toutes ses frontières qui
je comprends pas une chose c'est à dire
qu'il ya un système économique qui
existe qui s'appelle le libéralisme dont
vous avez entendu parler qui est une
notion de liberté là dedans libéralisme
la liberté de marché
ce que c'est que le libéralisme en
réalité c'est qu'une compagnie comme
nike peut s'installer au pakistan et
faire travailler toutes ces compagnies
là il a fait au pakistan il embauche que
des pakistanais ma chance ça travaille
par contre si un sol pakistanais veut
travailler aux états unis
alors là non 1 c'est un problème comment
peut-on se sentir libre quand son voisin
ne l'est pas comment
c'est possible dans ce monde alors là
heureusement grâce à internet
ces frontières sont gentiment en train
de disparaître je le dis parce que moi
quand j'étais petit j'avais des cousins
en irak
je n'ai pas dis tout de suite pour pas
vous effrayer il est barbu en plus il y
aura donc tout va bien
je tiens à dire que j'adore la déco de
la salle quand j'ai dit que j'allais
parler de l'optimisme du cas où j'ai cru
qu'ils avaient fait les spermatozoïdes
de sang ces ballons là c'est vraiment on
dirait le titre d'un livre de virginie
despentes les spermatozoïdes de sang
voilà parfois je m'égare voilà ça fait
normal faut laisser aller sa pensée en
fait si j'étais là je pensais à
spermatozoïdes de sang il fallait que je
sorte
ouais donc je disais simplement pour
revenir à quelque chose de plus sérieux
que moi quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai
appelé mes cousins en irak et c'était un
budget c'était un budget je sais qu'il y
en a qu'on connaît aussi une période en
france ou même ap la province fallait
faire le 16 et le 1 voilà et que ça
coûtait super cher aujourd'hui on peut
les appeler grâce à facebook en vision
je le vois gratos donc un mec en irak
peut savoir ce qui se passe un peu
partout dans le monde donc nous verrons
ça va être compliqué de mentir on est
encore certains gouvernements c'est
compliqué des frontières qui vont être
durs à péter je dire israël palestine
c'est pas la première qui va sauter tout
à ce que j'ai dit
mais je pense que là qu'on va y arriver
alors je sais ça va être si on pète les
frontières aujourd'hui ça va être le
chaos
et c'est pas grave c'est peut-être un
cadre nécessaire parfois voilà on pète
tout et ça va se rééquilibrait forcément
on va arrêter de vouloir vivre dans son
petit confort de sécurité et pas vouloir
partager on va aller nulle part comme ça
mais si justement il ya plus de
frontières on peut se poser une question
essentielle quelle sera la prochaine
fracture sociale
on peut on peut vraiment se poser je
pense pas que ce soit leur âge et
j'espère qu'on va oublier le racisme
qu'on va oublier tout ça aujourd'hui
n'importe qui peut être un roi
avant il fallait être d'une ligne de
sang noble pour être un roi
aujourd'hui on a des bill gates nos des
mecs tu vois il suffit de travailler dit
croire je sais que ça paraît un petit
peu utopique de dire comme ça mais
vraiment j'en suis la preuve on
travaille on y arrive vous faire ce
qu'on aime juste fait ce que vous aimez
sinon on se fait chier dans la vie
d'accord je pense que la prochaine
fracture sociale ça va être le
vocabulaire
ça va savoir s'exprimer savoir parler
c'est pour ça que c'est important ces
conférences je pense sincèrement que ça
va être la fracture sociale
elle sera là quand ceux qui seront
parler
ne diront plus à ceux qui ne savent pas
parler parce qu'avoir un manque de
vocabulaire
c'est ce frustré tout seul d'ailleurs ce
qui manque de vocabulaire sont
extrêmement violent ce canton s'est pas
parlé aux tarnais ont par contre j'y
crois toi ben ali dans ce délire comme
ça non faut évoluer en apprenant à
parler c'est plutôt pas mal et ça coûte
rien ça coûte juste des efforts ça fait
juste un peu de temps et en plus
aujourd'hui on a internet si on veut
j'ai appris à parler l'anglais juste
grâce à internet on peut faire des
choses j'ai appris à crocheter une
serrure sur internet vraiment tout
apprendre sur internet c'est génial tout
savoir c'est pas forcément négatif 1
tout ça pour vous dire que l'optimisme
avant tout
c'est pas subir c'est agir parce que
c'est facile d'être pessimiste et de
rien moi c'est bon être optimiste
et ne plus subir c'est agir c'est
défendre défendre son voisin et je veux
juste insister c'est aujourd'hui
défendre son voisin c'est pas défendre
sa propre paroisse moi je pense
sincèrement que le futur c'est quand des
hétéros défendront des homosexuels ce
qui n'a pas besoin d'être homosexuel
pour le défendre les droits des
homosexuels
c'est quand des mecs défendre le droit
des femmes c'est quand il suffit pas
d'être black pourrait être contre le
racisme ça que je veux dire aujourd'hui
damien suffit pas de de consommer du
cannabis pour être pour sa légalisation
ouais et de combat vous pouvez déjà un
qui m'arrangerait énormément que soit
légalisé
parce que je vous dire quand on apprend
que c'est légal dans d'autres pays là je
me sens en france je suis régulièrement
je sais que c'est légal ailleurs j'ai
l'impression d'être homosexuel en arabie
saoudite perdant je me dis que je me
casse dit si quoi donc le plus important
et je sais que à l'époque des réseaux
sociaux c'est très compliqué d'être
hermétique aux critiques qu'on entend
tous les jours mon en tant qu'humoriste
peux vous dire qu'on entend tous les
jours il suffit de dire la même là j'ai
dit que j'étais là bas ça se voit qu'ils
fument du cannabis regard qui raconte
l'histoire je sais qu'on va voir des
choses comme ça concentrez vous sur ce
que vous aimez n'écoutez pas ce qu'on a
à vous dire c'est soit positif ou
négatif
concentrez vous sur ce que vous pensez
être juste soyez vous soyez vous soyez
vous engagez vous merci beaucoup merci
infiniment
[Applaudissements]